welcome back a spending agreement
reached ahead of Friday's budget
deadline to avoid a government shutdown
the new continuing resolution uh would
fund government until March and would be
the third continuing resolution used to
fund government since September
Republicans have been pushing for any
agreement to include new security at the
southern border but this CR does not
appear to address that despite over
785,000 migrants encountered at the
southern border already this fiscal year
which began in October that includes a
new monthly record of 302,000 just last
month now Mexico's president is making a
list of Demands to the Biden
Administration for any of his help in
slowing the tide of the millions of
illegal border
crossings from more than 150 countries
it is unclear how much control the
dangerous drug cartels have on the
Mexican Government join me right now
with reaction is Utah Senator Mike Lee
he has vowed to vote against any funding
agreement until a border security deal
is in place Senator it's good to see you
this morning thanks very much for being
here thank you very much so so can you
walk us through these two spending
packages that have been discussed this
weekend the first one is the continuing
resolution that would take us into March
keep the government funded look we have
in place a massive humanitarian border
security crisis it's and it's a rule of
law crisis in order to resolve that all
we need is for the president of the
United States to exercise The Authority
that he already has and he's got more
than enough Authority the same Authority
president Trump had in order to secure
the border and he did President Biden
could do that and he should do that this
has reached such crisis proportions
which with
300,000 Crossing illegally across our
Southern Border in December alone that I
think it's time for us to tell the
government look you you've got to secure
the Border or shut it down so if if they
want their government funded especially
if they want every priority funded even
for a short period of time they need to
show us that they're willing to do this
we don't need new laws for this we
simply need the president to have the
resolve and if what that takes is the
threat of us withholding some of his
priorities or funding from his
administration so be it well I mean part
of the details that I was looking at
from the Senate bill that they are
proposing uh expulsion Authority for a
limited number of days only if border
encounters exceed 5,000 a day over 7-Day
period so are you suggesting that this
deal is telling your colleagues that
that the only way they will put security
at the border is after 5,000 illegals
are are enter a
day well that's one way of looking at it
we still don't have Bill text that's how
it's been explained to us in certain
terms in that they create a new
Authority for the president to uh you
know halt uh the flow of illegal aliens
across the border but that would kick in
only after they've had 5,000 plus
migrant encounters daily but here again
Maria this isn't uh necessary the the
the president doesn't need a new law
existing law would allow him to address
this he just refuses to do it and so
that's why it's so disconcerting that
they're saying a new law is necessary
moreover Maria even after that Authority
that new Authority they create kicks in
only after 5,000 Micron encounters a day
it would remain in effect uh only for a
maximum of 180 days a year after the
first few years I think the first year
is 275 days what that means is that the
Mexican drug cartels could then calender
their human trafficking you know keep in
mind they earn many many billions of
dollars a year off of Joe Biden's lack
border enforcement policies and they
could just frontend load that or backend
load that depending on what the calendar
allowed so this is a proposal that's
designed first and foremost not to
secure the Border but to extract and
extort votes from Republicans for this $
106 billion Aid package most of which
goes to Ukraine for which they're
understandably reluctant to vote that's
disgraceful well I mean the Senate
Republicans seem more interested in
sending money to Ukraine than actually
securing the Border when are Senate
Republicans going to get serious about
the
Border well it's time to get security
serious about the border right now and
the way we do that is to tell the Biden
Administration if you want your
Administration funded secure the border
secure the Border or shut it down the
very worst thing we could do right now
is give them more money for their
priorities for things uh like giving Aid
to help other countries secure their
borders while doing nothing that's
actually going to change President
Biden's will uh to enforce the law that
is his job he took an oath to do that
he's failing badly when it comes to the
border and the consequences are
catastrophic it result in in human
trafficking human sex trade it's it's a
roding lawlessness across our country
these things do have an effect and it's
harming Americans it's harming people
over the Western Hemisphere just
extraordinary what do the next few days
look like Senate goes back on Tuesday
and Schumer had set up a procedural vote
you said you don't even have text of any
of these spending plans when do you
expect a
vote okay so uh we do expect uh a vote
as early as Tuesday on the continuing
resolution but as far as the
supplemental Aid package uh we were
promised that we'd see text as early as
this Wednesday of this last week we now
promis that maybe we'll get to see Tex
sometime this next week in the meantime
we we we've got people pushing this deal
as if it were already a proposal we've
got the Wall Street Journal coming out
last Monday saying that any Republican
who didn't support the supplemental Aid
package was just trying to score cheap
political points at the expense of
American National Security I don't know
how they can say this when there is no
deal there is no proposal we haven't
even seen it mhm uh let me switch gears
ask you about your thoughts on Iowa I
see that you have endorsed president
Trump tell us why I've endorsed
president Trump we've got two choices
this is a binary Choice Americans face
in November and they face a choice
between lawlessness and the rule of law
they face a choice between secure
neighborhoods and communities and
absolute Lawless Mayhem uh the American
people need a return of Donald Trump
they need the return of someone who was
willing to secure our border was willing
to look out for American interests not
those of our adversaries not those of
foreign countries and do you get a sense
that others uh will be endorsing Trump
after Iowa when are you expecting him to
wrap up and lock up this nomination if
in fact that's what you
expect as a defacto matter Maria he's
going to have this wrapped up pretty
quickly uh because I I I don't see any
State uh coming up anytime soon where
he's going to start losing um I think
he's going to do really well in Iowa I
think he's going to do really well in
almost every state after that and uh so
yeah I I I think he will become the deao
presumptive nominee very very soon and I
welcome my colleagues in joining me in
getting behind Donald Trump in his
candidacy for 2024 you know I don't
understand why your colleagues on the
left are so against America first I
don't understand why they would allow uh
this wideopen border where we've
actually noted people who are on
terrorist watch list who've been
encountered and the fentol killing uh so
many you know 100,000 Americans in the
last year do you have a sense of
why you know it's very difficult to
speak for the subjective mindset of
someone else but I I can speculate and
some of the speculation I can offer
Maria has to do with the fact that when
you don't live on or near a border when
you don't live in or near a community uh
where bad things happen communities that
are not gated uh you might lose track so
uh Democratic office holders maybe are
are not spending as much time in these
communities as they should uh perhaps
they're not close enough to people who
are being killed by inflation who are
being uh harmed by the ravaging effects
of lawlessness and illegal immigration
but regardless they have a supremely
naive view of a world uh that that says
that we don't have to worry about our
border we do that's what a country is
yeah and we'll lose our country's
strength if we don't enforce our own
laws particularly those that protect our
border all right Senator we'll be
watching your work thanks very much for
being here this morning Senator Mike Lee
this morning exclusive hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else